hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast assessing the role of
prefrontal cortex in consciousness via a
new metric of functional connectivity
presented by Megan Peters PhD an
assistant professor of bioengineering at
the University of California Riverside I
am Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab Rhodes
laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions you want and any time you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Peters I will now turn the presentation
over to her thank you very much for
having me here at lab roots I'm very
excited to talk to you about the new
metric of functional connectivity that
we're developing here so before I begin
I want to very quickly acknowledge and
thank everybody who has made this
project possible I'm working closely
with a number of people at the
University of California Los Angeles as
well as researchers at ATR where the
data were collected and at Nagoya
University and so I also want to greatly
thank all of the support and technical
staff at ATR that's the advanced
telecommunications Research Institute
international in Kyoto Japan
and some other researchers who are not
specifically involved but are really
providing ongoing support and guidance
so the data I'm being I'm going to be
presenting today will also are they were
also collected with the support of the
funding sources that you see at the
bottom of your screen and also a
disclaimer this is very much a work in
progress the data that I'll be
presenting today and so I encourage you
to ask questions provide feedback and
hopefully we'll get to some sort of
interesting results later so without any
further ado let's get started
so the question that we wanted to answer
with this project which is really
fundamental to the study of the neural
correlates of consciousness is how is it
that the brain is able to bring a
low-level visual representation into
awareness so what I mean by this is what
computations or brain regions are
responsible for the fact that we can
become conscious of what our early
sensory areas are representing so there
are a lot of theories about what makes
something conscious so we have for
example global work space Theory local
recurrency theories integrated
information theory and so on
but the one that I tend to subscribe to
is what's called higher order thought
theory so in this theory for something
to rise into conscious awareness
prefrontal cortical regions must have
what's called a higher-order
representation which implies that they
have access to the information in some
way so what I mean by this is when a
lower order sensory area like visual
cortex or ventral temporal cortex is
representing some information like this
dog here that for you the guy in the
driver's seat to become consciously
aware of this thought your prefrontal
areas must have some sort of access and
therefore form a representation of this
dog as well so the theory is a good deal
of support but one kind of obvious way
to test it would be to see whether PS
having access to those low-level
representations means those
representations are consciously
accessible okay and we do have a good
deal of evidence that visited
potentially the right theory although it
is far from canon so even though it's
still controversial we see that maybe
the prefrontal cortex is in fact
necessary for achieving conscious
awareness
so some lesion data so this is where the
brain is damaged this is in support of
this theory so for example you can see
that bilateral lesions to the occipital
cortex so this is at the back of your
brain this can cause what's called
cortical blindness as you can't see but
you still have preserved awareness via
other modalities you're just as aware of
your surroundings via touch via smell
and so on the hearing so it's not really
damaging your awareness it's just
damaging your vision likewise you can
see that bilateral parietal lesions so
this is kind of at the top back of your
brain this can cause what's called
valence syndrome so the distant herb is
typically characterized by an inability
to perceive multiple objects in the
visual field simultaneously but again
this leaves basic sensory awareness
pretty much intact you can also see that
patients with bilateral orbital frontal
lesions so this is at the front and the
bottom of your brain but this can cause
problems with social cognition and
social regulation but again not sensory
perception or consciousness in contrast
though patients who have bilateral
prefrontal bleed lesions or PFC lesions
they're less conscious in the sense that
they're they're awake but they're so
they're not in a coma but they're they
really lack the ability to engage
meaningfully with the external world
with what might be thought of as a
normal level of conscious awareness so
all of these lesion studies really do
point to a pretty reasonable and
meaningful role
prefrontal cortex in in giving rise to
conscious awareness and some previous
work that we actually did using electric
choreography also supported this view so
electric or topography is where you
record directly from the surface of the
brain so this is in the context of
surgery for drug-resistant epilepsy
neurosurgeons will actually remove the
entire top of the head you take off the
top of your skull and you place
electrodes all over the brain and you
record neural activity while people are
looking at stimuli or doing some tasks
and what we showed in this study is that
when it comes to confidence judgments
about perception so these are kind of
being metacognitive or awareness
judgments about what you subjectively
are seeing that we see a much more
distributed pattern in terms of which
cortical areas are involved so the
bottom panel on the right of your screen
shows that when you're judging
confidence all of your brain is really
involved and that we see a distinct role
of frontal regions but when we're
looking at just the perception itself
that you see a much stronger rule of
occipital cortex so it seems that once
again we have some reasonable evidence
that prefrontal cortex may be actually
involved in conscious awareness okay so
then it's a theory about prefrontal
cortexes involvement and conscious
awareness but again the way that we need
to test this theory is by showing that
when prefrontal cortex has access to
low-level
visual representations that those
representations then become conscious
the problem however is how do we define
or measure what prefrontal cortex has
access to and then we need to also
define this measure on a trial by trial
basis so that we can say on this trial
you were consciously aware and on this
child you were not consciously aware so
that's really what we need to do here so
to answer the first part here we can say
or we can define what prefrontal cortex
has access to as what prefrontal cortex
is functionally connected to so
functional connectivity in its most
basic form in especially fMRI research
the traditional way to measure this
functional connectivity between two
regions of the brain with fMRI is to
really just measure the ko variation in
the blood oxygen level dependent signal
or the bulbs signal over time between
these two regions so you take the two
regions and you measure the response of
those regions to a particular stimulus
and you just correlate the response in
time and that gives you a measure of
connectivity and what we can do is we
want to measure how that connectivity
changes over time so now this is called
dynamic functional connectivity and the
principle is the same only you can do
these correlations now between two
regions of interest or ro is in the
finding window so you pick a sliding
window length which is typically between
30 to 60 seconds on average and you'll
measure the correlations between two
regions of interest within that time
window and there are other free
approaches of course you can do tum
frequency analysis especially with
imaging modalities that have higher
temporal precision then you get an fMRI
where every picture is every two seconds
essentially and there are a number of
reasons why this dynamic functional
connectivity is really powerful but for
the purposes of our approach to measure
what prefrontal cortex has access to on
a trial by trial basis there are some
really kind of obvious limitations that
we would need to address the first one
is that the 32 660 second time window it
really doesn't give us much temporal
precision at all especially if we want
to measure the trial by trial
connectivity and our trials are less
than a whole minute long and
additionally the window size remains
arbitrary you know the reasons to pick
30 or 60 seconds can kind of differ
from one study to the next and you can
also decide whether you use a
rectangular window or a window that kind
of tapers off at the edges of time so we
wanted to see whether we could improve
on these existing methods and to find a
way to measure essentially near
instantaneous functional connectivity
between two regions using fMRI or
functional neuroimaging okay so that's
the necessary first step in our roadmap
here in order to measure whether
consciousness depends on trial by travel
connectivity between prefrontal regions
and lower order perceptual areas we have
to define a metric that will give us the
temporal precision we need using fMRI we
can then see whether this metric changes
over time as a function of training for
example and then we can ask our critical
question about whether functional
connectivity between PSD or prefrontal
cortex and these lower order visual
areas is actually related to conscious
access okay so this is our road map so
let's start by defining this new
connectivity metric okay so to define
the new connectivity metric we're going
to start with a basis as a
representational similarity analysis or
RSA so representational similarity
analysis essentially compares the multi
voxel pattern so voxel is a
three-dimensional picture pixel a
picture of your brain so we'll compare
the multi voxel patterns produced by one
stimulus to those produced by a
different stimulus so for example I show
you a face and then I measure the multi
voxel pattern of activity in say ventral
temporal cortex or VT and then I show
you a house and I measure the pattern of
bold activity in those same voxels
then to compare these patterns I to get
an idea of how similar they might be I
can essentially just correlate the
patterns across space so I can line up
all the voxels into a one dimensional
array and from from voxel one to voxel n
within a particular ROI or region of
interest and then I can so I line up all
the voxels from one pattern one stimulus
and that I line up the same voxels from
a different stimulus and then I just
correlate the patterns across based I
can just use a Pearson correlation and
this will give me an R value which
varies between 0 to 1 and I can use its
R value to say how similar or dissimilar
these patterns are and this is great and
I can even decide to do this at every TR
every time the fMRI takes a whole brain
volume the whole image of your brain and
I could look at how those correlations
change from one TR to the next or one
trial to the next so this could be super
useful in comparing the patterns across
multiple stimuli within a given region
and assuming the region can
differentiate between the stimuli of
different categories the voxels will do
so so for example in this ventral
temporal cortex region if I run this
representational similarity analysis I
should see a higher degree of similarity
between the two dog images because
they're from the same kind of image
category then between the dog and say
the horse image okay and so that's great
and I can also do the same thing within
a different region of interest that I
care about let's say a higher-order
region like PSC prefrontal cortex so I
should probably find kind of a similar
result that the dogs will be more
similar to each other in terms of their
representational pattern than they are
to the horse but what if I want to
compare across regions
I can't just line up the vault holds and
do a correlation like I did within a
single region because it's not the same
voxels right so they're going to respond
in a different way maybe I even have a
different
number of voxels in each area because
they're different sizes mental temporal
cortex might be bigger than the
prefrontal cortex region of interest or
it might be smaller than the region of
interest that I care about so basic
representational similarity analysis
really isn't going to cut it here so to
compare between two regions of interests
that have different voxels or even
different numbers of voxels we'd have to
find something to correlate it isn't
spatially dependent so what if we could
correlate the strength of the
representation across different contexts
but in an abstract sense rather than a
spatial sense so this is no longer which
voxels are active and how much and
correlate the voxels it's more like
which ideas are active or which concepts
are active and how much and then we can
look at how those patterns are similar
between two regions the problem is we're
going to need a lot more than two or
three ideas to correlate or compare
between the two areas
the brain can represent a whole lot more
than dog or umbrella or horse and that's
it
right and the other problem here is that
running a correlation with only three
data points isn't really going to get us
much useful or meaningful information so
we're going to need a contact strength
measure for a lot of different concepts
that will allow us to correlate them or
compare them across the entire kind of
conceptual space in the two completely
separate regions of interest in the
brain so the question then becomes how
do we get this concept strength measure
which you see on the y-axis of these
little cartoon bar plots that I've shown
typically if we're using multi voxel
pattern decoding we could get a binary
or possibly trinary output wherein we
use a support vector machine decoding or
a logistic regression and this Y value
which we'd call concept strength here
this can then be replaced by the
probability of a particular concept or a
particular idea so this is a probability
value it's between 0 and 1 and these are
Alliance now socially so that when you
add up all of the concepts the
probability for all the concepts you get
one out of it so essentially we get a
probability distribution and then we
could use metrics that measure the
similarity or difference between
probability distributions to compare the
informational content between the two
areas and we need to do this in a way
that we don't get only two or three
categories out of it we need to get a
lot of categories so we need to run
what's called a multinomial regression
or multinomial classifier so we get it
say 40 categories instead of just three
but here's where we run into another
bottleneck to Train even a binary or
trinary decoder it takes a lot of data
so to train a decoder that has like 40
categories we really need a huge amount
of sample data to build a stable
meaningful decoder that actually has
some chance of decoding the true
probability of different concepts in a
particular area and not just noise but
if we can get around that possibly by
using a lot of people instead of just
one person so now we have a lot of
people view the exact same sequence of
images to build the decoder and then we
can functionally align the voxels
in various regions of interest and then
we can pull all the data from many
subjects and use that to Train decoder
so now I'm going to tell us how we
functionally align my voxels to your
foxholes so that we can take all of the
data from your brain and all of the data
from from my brain and put them together
into like one super subject brain and I
can do this now from a lot of people
okay so to do the functional alignment
the first thing we have to do is make
sure this everybody sees the exact same
sequence of images of events and this
allows us to map the trajectory of
activity of one of my boxes onto one of
your voxels across time within the same
region of interest right so we're
interested in categorical
representations that is
what degree a particular region of
interest represents dog or cat or horse
or chair or umbrella in a given moment
so we'll present our participants with a
sequence of images which come from these
various categories and then we'll
measure the neural response the bullet
signal in response to these images in
ventral temporal cortex and impre--
frontal cortex well these people watch
the images and be concerned nobody falls
asleep in the scanner here we go and
that they're paying attention to the
categories of these objects we'll ask
our participants to look at the images
and the depressive button whenever they
see the category of the image changing
so in this particular sample sequence we
see dog dog dog dog and then we see
horse horse horse and so at the point
where the category switches from dog
Kapoor's the participant in the fMRI
scanner would press the button ok and we
have 38 people do this oh sorry we're
first we're we're measuring the activity
and ventral temporal cortex and
prefrontal cortex while people are doing
this and then we have 30 people do this
each person sees 3,600 trials so this is
90 exemplars 90 different cats
90 different dogs in each of 40
categories that we care about okay and
so now we can do that functional
alignment so we can pull all of the data
from the 38 people in order to train our
multivariate machine learning decoder so
this functional alignment is called
hyper alignment it uses essentially
linear transformations scaling rotation
and translation to find the best mapping
between the vowels in my brain and the
voxels in your brain within a region of
interest in terms of how they react to
this stimuli so it finds the volatile in
my brain that responds this much to dog
and this much to can an intermediate to
horse and it finds the voxel in your
brain that responds in a similar way
okay I done this using these linear
translations here are trained
transformations - okay then it's going
to do the same thing mapping the bottles
of 1/3
person on to the transformations that it
found for you and me and so on and so on
for all 38 people and we'll do this for
a thousand voxels in each region of
interest to find a common space for all
participants
so these voxels now represent the the
voxel in my brain and in your brain and
in that person's brain over there that
all respond very similarly to all of
these categories so the beautiful thing
about this now is that once you've
you've trained these transformation
matrices you can actually transform the
data from every single person into this
common space and now you have 3600
images times 38 people which is 136
thousand eight hundred trials and this
is actually maybe enough to train that
40 Way classifier that we really care
about okay so the next thing that we
have to do is we have to train the
classifier and make sure that we have
enough data to actually do that okay so
we could have used lots of different
machine learning approaches but we chose
logistic regression because it has the
advantage of simplicity its output
literally represents the probability of
one versus another category so in binary
logistic progression when you get out of
the fitted model is is the probability
of category a and then probability of
category B is one minus that but a
multinomial logistic regression what you
get out of the fitted model is a
probability distribution it's a
distribution over the the possible
categories that the model is trying to
predict so essentially this is the
likelihood that the multivariate pattern
that you're observing in ventral
temporal cortex VT or PFC which is
prefrontal cortex the probability that
that pattern in that region of interest
represents this particular conceptual
category so that's what I plotted here
again this term cartoon bar clock so you
can see that ventral temporal cortex or
prefrontal cortex what you get out of
the decoder is this probability
distribution so the ventral temporal
cortex in the in the cartoon that I've
created is probably representing snake
and is less likely representing B and is
less likely representing giraffe whereas
prefrontal cortex is very strongly
representing B and very not strongly
representing a snake okay and we can
decide whether the decoder is correct if
the tallest bar the most probable
category for each one of these M flower
images in that decoder construction
session is actually the image that the
person was viewing when that brain
pattern was created so this gives us a 1
in 40 chance of being right by chance
and then we can see whether our decoder
is actually doing better than chance and
predicting what the person was looking
at on every trial and if the decoder is
doing a good job then we know that the
decoder is actually picking up on
something meaningful in these patterns
okay and so what we see here is that in
Bentall temporal cortex so this is 6
fold cross validated for those of you
who care about that stuff in ventral
temporal cortex we see that the decoder
is doing massively above chance so we
have a 1 in 5 chance of being correct in
just randomly guessing are in guessing
whether or what the category is that the
person was viewing on a trial by trial
basis in prefrontal cortex we're doing a
little bit worse prefrontal cortex is
notoriously difficult to decode but we
are actually still getting above chance
decoding again chance is 1 out of 40 and
we're a little bit above that so this
shows us that these decoders are
actually picking up on something
meaningful in these two areas which is
great and now we can take the output of
these decoders which apparently is
meaningful and that output again is a
probability distribution across the
possible categories or contexts that
these areas could be representing so
we're going to use standard ways of
comparing
probability distributions to measure the
relationship between these two predicted
outcomes so we will use we will define
as our new functional connectivity
metric something called functional
information transmission or fit and this
is essentially taking the
kullbackleibler divergence which is the
match between those two probability
distributions in terms of their shape
and then we will also take into account
the entropy of these distributions and
this is essentially how two spiky the
distributions are so we want entropy and
the kullbackleibler divergence to be low
we want the two distributions that are
predicted in the two areas to be very
similar and very spiky we want them to
be very strongly representing whatever
it is that they're representing and not
very strongly representing other things
if the probability distribution were
flat across all of the possible
categories then the decoder seems to be
just randomly guessing and that's not
what we want so by this definition
smaller fit is better we want
kullbackleibler divergence and entropy
to both be small okay so let's take a
look at how fit does now in capturing
whether the person is viewing a an image
consciously or viewing an image
unconsciously and the way that we do
this unconscious viewing is by taking
two images from the same category but
they're different images and we look at
the pattern of predicted responses in
ventral temporal cortex and prefrontal
cortex when both of the areas are
simultaneously looking at the same image
like this versus when they're looking at
different images from the same category
okay so we'll halt online viewing this
is when both areas are viewing the same
trial and offline comparison we take the
patterns from different trials but the
same category in the two regions of
interest and we can see that fit is
significantly smaller or better for
cases where both regions of interest are
actually simultaneously and consciously
viewing the same object so this is our
first indication that fit actually may
index something mean
about conscious access or conscious
functional connectivity between
prefrontal cortex and ventral temporal
cortex so that's nice and then we can
also do a similar thing for comparing
two different exemplars within the same
category to two different exemplars that
come from different categories so if
what this metric is measuring is the
representational similarity in
information space between these two
regions of interest we should see cases
where the two dog patterns are more
similar to each other than a dog and an
umbrella or a dog and a horse so this is
very similar to the representational
similarity that we talked about earlier
and indeed this is exactly what we see
so we see that between category
functional information transmission is
always worse than within category fit
and we can confirm this with ANOVA and
t-test and other statistical tests like
that okay so this is great we've now
developed at least and then at least
preliminarily validated a metric that
may allow us to measure this
instantaneous functional connectivity or
informational similarity between two
regions of interest and we've shown that
between prefrontal cortex and ventral
temporal cortex this metric does seem to
index some things we care about having
to do with conscious access to low-level
visual representations when two regions
contain similar informational content
the fit metric is able to capture that
and it also is able to capture whether
the two areas are looking at the same
thing versus different things from the
same category so this is really nice now
we're going to be able to move on to two
and three within our roadmap and we
actually designed an experiment that
would try to provide answers to both two
and three in the same paradigm so I'm
going to introduce that design now and
then I'll show you some results that we
have from our pilot subjects and again
as a disclaimer this really is a work in
progress so the results that I just
showed you we have a lot of people and
we feel pretty confident in the result
but the new results come
to show you we only have a few people so
take what I'm showing you with a grain
of salt just because we haven't you know
maybe come up with a complete answer yet
doesn't mean we're not the right track
okay so our behavioral paradigm it's a
real-time functional neuroimaging study
and in this study subjects will undergo
blocks of trials that look basically
like this so on every trial we're going
to first show you a dot and you're
supposed to look at the dot this is what
you're lying in the scanner and then
during what we're going to call the
induction period we asked participants
to concentrate on changing their brain
activity and the goal of changing your
brain activity during this period is to
maximize the feedback that we're going
to give you which will earn you money so
during this this induction period we
will decode the two regions of interest
the ventral temporal cortex and the
prefrontal cortex and then we'll
calculate the fit between them and then
we'll show you a dot again and then
we'll show you some feedback and this
feedback the circle size is related to
UM the the fit that we calculated during
that induction period so if you did a
good job then you see a big circle and
you get a lot of money and if you did a
bad job you see a small circle and you
don't earn very much money and
importantly the circle size here this is
related to the functional information
transmission so if the fit is good
between the two regions if they're
representing the same kind of thing even
though there's nothing on the screen
then we'll give you a big feedback
circle okay and the way that this works
then is that we'll have on one day we'll
do the decoder construction and then
we'll do three days of this decoded
neuro feedback or deque Neph and I'll
get to those protons that you see in the
title in a second but first we see our
we show people you know eight to ten
runs of sixteen trials per run every day
so this is pretty intense and pretty
exhausting for our participants okay so
we first wanted to see whether this
decoded neuro feedback leads to better
fit over time that is whether people can
learn to better monitor
their own low-level perceptual
representations so now while we had
eight people go through the whole
experiment only four of them received
multiple days of training in which the
feedback measure was based on fit we
were piloting so several subjects
received feedback that was based on a
slightly different metric so we'll
remove those subjects from our analysis
and now we have only four left
unfortunately but now we're going to
look at whether fit changes over time as
a result of training so with these four
subjects we don't see a whole lot of
trends emerging fit however there may be
other trends in the learning that we
can't see just by looking at at fit so
for that we're going to have to dig
deeper into what it means to have
conscious access to a low level
representation in the first place
okay so now we're going to move on to
number three in our roadmap and then
we're going to go back and see whether
any of those metrics change so to answer
whether people are learning to improve
conscious access over the course of
training we have to actually define how
we're going to measure that conscious
access beyond just the fit metric itself
so now we have eight people that we can
look at for this because the feedback
for all of them doesn't matter for this
measure of conscious access which I'll
show you right now okay so in this
real-time fMRI paradigm we show the
structure that I showed you before but
then we also have these additional prove
trials that I mentioned earlier so
occasionally instead of showing the
feedback circle right away well actually
show two pictures on the screen so these
pictures are from the same categories as
the decoder construction images that we
saw earlier in the presentation and
we'll choose these images based on what
the brain happens to be representing
during this induction period so during
that induction period that noise screen
we're decoding the two regions of
interest and then I'm going to I choose
the images that I'll show you in the pro
trials based on the decoded
probabilities of those categories during
that induction period and I'll get to
how I actually choose or which images I
choose in the second
but I want to point out that during this
noise period that induction period where
you're changing your brain activity I'm
not actually showing anything on the
screen here okay but I'm going to lie to
my participants and I'm going to tell
them that sometimes inside the noise
there is also a picture being shown so
this gets them to try to look for
pictures within that noise okay and how
do they choose which image they think
was embedded in the noise they have to
read their confidence in their choice on
a scale of one to four okay and then
they get their feedback and the feedback
of course is unrelated to this choice
and confidence kind of questioning it's
really just based on how well you were
able to change your brain activity to
match the conceptual representations
between prefrontal cortex and ventral
temporal cortex and because we wanted to
really focus on having people change
their brain activity we have only up to
30% of these proof trials on every given
run on every day okay so I told you I
would tell you how these probe trial
images are shown shown and chosen so
remember we're not actually showing
anything in the noise even though we're
telling our participants that we are so
instead we're choosing our targets so
this is the correct answers and the
distractors the wrong answers on the
basis of the decoding that we do during
that induction period so the target is
always the most likely category from the
ventral temporal decoding so that is
always what your ventral temporal cortex
is most likely representing so in the
cartoon bar graph that I've shown here
ventral temporal cortex is most strongly
representing the snake so snake would
become the target on this probe trial
now the distractors can fall into two
categories
on half of the trials we choose the
least likely category from ventral
temporal decoding so in this cartoon bar
graph that I've created this becomes the
shark category in the other half of the
probe trials we're going to choose the
most likely category from the prefrontal
cortex decoding so in this cartoon bar
graph this becomes the B category okay
so we tell all of these
trials with essentially 50/50
probability and then we measure choices
and confidence in response okay and then
we're going to have one day of dakar
construction as we described earlier
then we'll have up to three days of that
real-time behavioral procedure okay so
to look at whether prefrontal cortex
connectivity predicts conscious access
we're going to use what's called choice
probability analysis so this type of
analysis allows us to see to what degree
a particular metric in this case the fit
metric is diagnostic of an observers
choices so can we predict what the
observer is going to choose what the
person is going to choose and other
aspects of their behavior like their
confidence using this particular metric
okay so our big question of course is
whether fit the relational similarity
between prefrontal cortex and ventral
temporal cortex does this predict what
people are going to choose and so what
we'll do to do this is we'll say okay if
it is very large so it's very bad will
predict at this particular criterion
that you're going to be incorrect and
then if it is very good then like it's a
two then will predict that you'll get
the choice correct between those two
pictures and so we can then plot what's
called the false alarm rate against the
hit rate and we can call this particular
criterion level at which would make
these predictions a and then we'll move
that criterion and change our
predictions so now we predict that at an
intermediate level of fit we predict
that you're going to be incorrect and so
this becomes a correct rejection whereas
for the point a it was a false alarm and
so now we get a different dot on this
curve and we can say that the area under
this receiver operating characteristic
curve so this is a signal detection
theory for you nerds out there this is
called the choice probability okay so
choice probability at 0.5 or 50% is
purely guessing choice probability of 1
is perfect prediction and
we really want it to be somewhere in
between okay so now kind of the crux of
the argument here getting towards the
end so the first trial type we're going
to look at is these against lowest
ventral temporal cortex or against
lowest VT probe trials and the question
is does better fit mean that the
observer is more likely to choose the
target and unfortunately the answer does
seem to be no we did not see that choice
probability is any different from 0.5
but again remember we only have 8 people
going through this and some of them
don't even have 3 days of training so we
do still have a pretty limited amount of
data we did some other choice
probability analyses to see if there
were some other patterns that might be
interesting in the data so we looked at
the probability of the target so that's
the height of that bar in the ventral
temporal cortex minus the probability of
the distractor to the height of that
really super tiny bar in the ventral
temporal cortex and we don't see any
patterns here either and we also don't
see that your confidence ratings
meaningfully predict whether you're
going to be correct or incorrect on a
trial by trial basis now in the against
the highest PFC probe trials maybe we
have a slightly better shot so
unfortunately we don't see any
relationships between fit and your trial
by trial ability to preach is the target
however we do now see that the
difference between the height of the bar
and ventral temporal cortex that defines
the target and the height of the bar in
prefrontal cortex that defines the
distractor the difference between these
bars now actually does predict which one
people are going to choose so a ventral
temporal cortex is more strongly
representing whatever it's representing
then you choose the ventral temporal
cortex target and likewise if prefrontal
cortex is more strongly representing
whatever it happens to be representing
then that's the one that you choose in
this choice we also see that there might
be a little bit of predictive power in
the confidence ratings so that when
people indicate higher confidence
they're more likely to choose that
target and now we can go back and we can
use the choice probably
analysis and subjects for whom the
feedback was consistent and meaningful
and we can take a look at how their
behavior and those profiles involves
over time so first in these four people
remember we only have four people here
now we are starting to see the
confidence ratings baby predictive of
your choice even in those against louis
VT trials and that we retain the ability
of the difference between the height of
the bar for the target and the height of
the bar for the distractor this still
predicts your choice in those against
highest PFC trials we also see maybe
that there is some learning in your
ability to access this low level
representation over time we just might
not have seen it in the fit metric just
yet so we finally looked at whether the
overall trial number this is basically
how far you've gotten through the
training protocol is this likely to
predict your accuracy on this two
alternative forced choice and the answer
is yes barely so remember we only have
four people here but we're starting to
see that maybe with training people do
have the ability to gain access to their
low-level representations so now we need
to see why our fit metric may not
capture this and how we can refine our
fit metric to be able to predict these
types of behavioral responses and of
course the disclaimer this is a work in
progress we have a very small number of
subjects and so we want to temper our
excitement about this until we have some
further proof that it might be correct
okay so in the summary of what I
presented today we have to find a new
connectivity metric this is done we
validated it although we do need to do
some more work to refine it we've
targeted with it with decoded
neurofeedback to see whether people can
learn to improve it and we've tried to
relate it to conscious awareness and
these are works that are definitely
still in progress so there's some open
questions of course in future directions
that are our research is going to take
so we're going to further validate our
fit match
if we're going to compare it to
representational similarity analysis
within each region of interest using for
example k-means clustering we're going
to compare fit to traditional dynamic
functional connectivity we're going to
relate fit to the default mode network
activity and of course we need to
collect some more data so with that I'd
like to thank all of you for your
attention I'd like to once again thank
all of my collaborators without remove
this work but definitely not be possible
and I'd like to thank libraries for
hosting this event
thank you dr. Peters for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is have you ever thought about
using hyper alignment to align VT and
PFC to make fit work better yeah this is
a great question that I've gone before
so I think this is in principle a great
idea that we can look at how we can
better align the representational
content in VT and in PSC if we do some
sort of hyper alignment to line
everything up to begin with um the
challenge here is that the way that
ventral temporal cortex and prefrontal
cortex represent these kinds of ideas
might kind of cluster differently and
what I mean by that is that when ventral
temporal cortex thinks about something
that's kind of similar to a dog it might
care about things that have four legs
and so it might say dogs and chairs and
tables are very similar to each other
and dogs and chickens and snakes are not
very similar to each other and in
contrast when prefrontal cortices are
just examples by the way the prefrontal
cortex might cluster concepts kind of
differently so maybe prefrontal cortex
cares more about anima c than ventral
temporal
Sextus so prefrontal cortex is going to
say that dogs and tables are very
dissimilar even though they both have
four legs and that dogs and chickens and
snakes are more similar to each other so
the the hyper alignment is the linear
transformation and so there may be
challenges in trying to deal with the
the linearity of that transformation
that would not take into account these
differences in essentially the very
centers of the clusters so I well this
is a great idea in theory and we're
looking into ways of doing this type of
transformation to to modify the fit and
metric and make it better
we we don't have the answer quite yet
but great question next one is what were
some of the other versions of fit you
tried and do they work in predicting
conscious awareness any differently yeah
this is also a great question the the
first thing that we tried actually was
we we didn't look at entropy at all so
entropy is essentially the the spiciness
of the probability distribution so
whether the probability distribution
over those those conceptual categories
is very strongly horse for example and
like nothing else or whether it's just
kind of like sort of horse and sort of
chicken and sort of giraffe and so
initially we we didn't use entropy and
we just used the kullbackleibler
divergence which is the degree to which
to probability distributions are similar
regardless of their spike enos and we
found that one of my participants in
particular was very um was very smart in
figuring out this task and so she she
figured out how to make her brain
represent essentially nothingness all
the categories at once and so then her
the the decoding showed that the two
areas that we care about had very
similar representations because they
were very similarly representing nothing
and so we had to change the metric to
incorporate entropy or the spiciness of
the distributions in order to counteract
that so we're looking at
other ways of defining fit too we try
the straight Pearson correlation and
that didn't work really well so we're
still open to suggestions so if you have
any suggestions please feel free to
email me and let me know
one more question could you use this
metric in other neuro imaging modalities
yeah this is also a very good question
in principle you could any neuro imaging
modality that would allow you to decode
in a multivariate way and in a
multinomial way so you need to the
critical thing is that you need to have
many different categories that you're
decoding among you can't just have a
binary or a trinary decoder but really
we're not tied to the fMRI imaging
modalities so any imaging modality that
would allow you to get kind of a
multi-dimensional probability
distribution out of it would would lend
itself to fit or wherever fit ends up
after we do more research on it so yeah
you could use this with EEG you could
use it with a lot of other neuro imaging
modalities in humans and and non-human
animals as well if you wanted to again I
would like to once again thank dr.
Peters for her presentation I would also
like to thank lab routes for making
today's educational webcast possible
before I go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through June 15
2018 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share at this announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye